Myesha is with us in New York hi Maya
how are you I'm good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up I just
want to ask you a question I'm a
divorced mom for kids my income is maybe
if I add my second job in about thirty
to a year my debt is roughly about
66,000 and some change if you could tell
me how long you think it might take me
to pay this off well you live in a very
very very high cost of living area don't
you yes but I also live in public
housing so I'm definitely one of your
lower end income people yeah so my rent
is based on my my income okay so how
much is your rent 705 okay on a thirty
two thousand dollar income with four
kids yes a daughter in college and three
sons a senior in high school sophomore
in high school and a seventh grader and
child support is sporadic she's trying
to be nice okay that's a difficult road
you know I mean your your income in that
in that New York City environment your
income with four kids I don't know how
you're making it even with the $750
house payment when they're when they're
gone and child support is gone for sure
unless you're trying to collect back
child support at that point which you
probably would be owed if you just call
me and say I'm single I make thirty two
thousand and I and I have $60,000 in
debt and I live in New York City I would
be hoing I don't know how you're gonna
do that yeah
so what I would tell you is this in
order for you to call me back ten or
twenty years from now and be very very
wealthy and prosperous and having a
wonderful money life
something's going to have to change
dramatically the numbers you're giving
me aren't going to lead you there okay
so one of the one of two things will
change either you're going to do
something with your career that triples
your income because it takes six figures
to exist in New York City or you're
moving yes to another area of the
country that has different opportunities
and a different cost of living now that
might be when the kids are gone three
years from now you might suffer through
and break even for three years but I
don't think you're gonna be paying off a
ton of debt with four kids seven or $50
rent and $32,000 income in New York City
you're not I mean if you pay off if you
pay the payments on your debt I think
you're doing well and paying the
payments as a 20 year plan yeah so I'm
not trying to give you no hope I'm just
saying you have a small shovel a big
hole yeah and it's like you know I got a
TSP and I'm out in the yard trying to
dig a ditch and so I want to challenge
you to say okay if we're gonna stay put
in this area what are we gonna do with
our career to get my income up on a
temporary basis and on a long-term basis
by even changing careers and what do you
do for a living I'm an office manager so
that and I just got that that job and
I'm probably gonna need to go back to
school to finish my degree which will
mean having to probably take out a loan
and maybe it depends on what agree
you're finishing and where you're
working maybe you work someplace that
pays for your degree to be finished yes
that's that's true I could I do plan on
possibly looking at and maybe you don't
need a degree I don't know what you're
gonna do
don't just assume more education as
always the answer I want you to lay out
what do I want are you 44 okay so what
do I want to be when I'm 54 that pays
$75,000 a year okay now I got 10 years
so what are my steps to get there now
that will get you out of that not not in
two years
probably not in three years but it'll
probably get you out of that in five
years but sitting where you're sitting
is probably a ten-year plan yeah and
that's that's really that's really
disheartening so I'm glad you got a new
job I'm glad you've got some support on
the housing right now and that keeps the
wolf away from the door that's good
but now we've we've got to got the
survival Oh taken care of now past
survival how do we prosper yeah just
real quick I want to thank you because
of reading your books I actually started
reading the Bible again well I was back
in reference the passages that you wrote
and Total Money Makeover and even though
I knew I wasn't in the income bracket it
just it took me back to the Bible so
I've started reading that again so thank
you well thank you I want you to
understand I'm not saying someone can't
make it at $32,000 income you can make
it at 32,000 our income but you want you
live in the one of the two most
expensive places in America to do that
and so that's very very very very
difficult add to that for kids add to
that sporadic lot in quotes child
support so you know you just you need a
break and you're thinking about it so
you're not stuck
you're not stuck you just need a path
you get need a flashlight and a path on
how to get out of this cave you know do
that do that but work on the income side
of the equation or relocate within 36
months okay one of those two things and
let's get your stuff but let's get you
going in in that direction and hold on
I'm going to send you a copy of another
book you need to read called start and
you're doing a good job you've already
more than started but really proud of
you very well done with all the
decisions you're making and you you are
in the process of completely changing
your life I see big things for you in
the future we got to change the math of
your situation this is the Dave Ramsey
show